so these are the lungs they are vital
organs in tetrapods which is anything
with four limbs and a spine as well as
some fish and some snails in humans they
go about here and they allow the body to
take in oxygen and get rid of carbon
dioxide which is what we call
respiration unfortunately though quite a
lot can go wrong with thongs and stop
them from working including cystic
fibrosis idiopathic pulmonary fibrosis
primary pulmonary hypertension and a
whole bunch of other things that I'm not
even going to attempt to pronounce so we
do have all sorts of ways of trading
most of these problems but sometimes a
pair of lungs will get to the point
where they simply will not work so
humans being the fairly remarkable sons
of monkeys that we are have worked out a
way to actually pull out old
dysfunctional lungs and replace them
with new working lungs from someone who
doesn't need them which is someone who
isn't breathing which is someone who is
dead so anyway we open up the organ
recipient stick in the new lungs connect
up the tubes and off they go breathing
like a champion for the rest of their
merry lives or that's the idea the
reality as usual is far more complicated
and depressing only about half of all
lung transplant patients survive for
five years after the operation and about
a third last 10 years the main reason
for this is the response of the immune
system which tends to reject the new
lungs and try and destroy them this is
called transplant rejection so let's
zoom in a little
human cells in fact the cells of all
vertebrates have what's called major
histocompatibility complex molecules in
their cell membranes these molecules
identify a cell as being self or
non-self the immune system being as nfo
big bastard attacks all non-self
material this works pretty well most of
the time but of course when someone
else's lungs are put in someone's body
the MHC shows it to be foreign so the
immune system notably the t-cells do
their job and do their very best to
destroy it now having your own body try
to destroy your lungs from the inside is
um not good if it gets really bad it's
called chronic rejection which in the
case of lungs manifests itself as
bronchiolitis obliterans which is
exactly as pleasant as it sounds
basically the little bronchiole ease of
the lungs get damaged and filled up with
scar tissue and inflammation eventually
leading to a lot of coughing and death
so um we don't want that and there are a
few ways which we clever made bags have
actually managed to reduce transplant
rejection now variation in the MHC the
molecule that identified cells as
cellphone non-self can be examined
before a transplant takes place so when
looking for an appropriate donor organ
we try and find one with very similar
MHC to the recipient there are actually
global databases of donor and recipient
information to aid in finding the best
match so a good match is a little like a
fake ID with a bit of luck the organ
recipients immune system won't notice
the difference in MHC and it won't
attack the transplanted organ the immune
system is pretty hard to trick though
and it usually catches on eventually so
you have to do something pretty drastic
and actually reduce the function of the
immune system this is achieved through
the use of immunosuppressant drugs
there's a myriad of such drugs available
and treatment offer a lung transplant
usually involves a cocktail of them
which is used for the rest of the
patient's life one of the major ones is
cyclosporine which incidentally was
discovered by Norwegians in a fungus
called tulip declare them inflate them
so cyclosporine is specifically aimed
via rubella comprehensible chain of
reactions at T cells which are one of
the main players in transplant rejection
it basically stops them from working
properly thus protecting the donor and
lungs
the immunosuppressant drugs though
pretty fiddly and dangerous because if
the immune system is impaired the body
becomes suddenly vulnerable to infection
and other threats that would normally
not be a big deal so it's about finding
a balance between these risks so by
first minimizing MHC differences then
using a regimen of immunosuppressant
drugs we can do a pretty good job of
keeping transplanted lungs working in
the recipients body as stated before the
lung transplant so really a temporary
treatment as very few people last more
than ten years with transplanted plans
before bronchiolitis obliterans or some
other complication takes hold and the
patient dies but if a lung transplant
and give someone a few more years of
breathing it's probably not a bad thing
unrelated note it'll be really rather
good if everyone signed up with an organ
donor Australia has one of the lowest
donation rates in the developed world
even though the success rate of the
transplants that do happen is one of the
best in the world a thousand one
Australians were saved donated organs
last year but there are still about
1,600 people waiting to sign up go to
donate life gov dot a you because you
really don't need your organs once
you're dead no matter what the ancient
Egyptians believed so lung transplants
pretty good with a pretty interesting I
hope you found this video informative
and watchable you can find the
references and whatnot in the text below
thanks